this video is sponsored by friends and
dragons
hello do you like dragons do you like
friends
not particularly in that order
introducing friends
and dragons twice the fun in one
free-to-play rpg game which is available
on the app store and google play delve
through
dungeons with completely skill-driven
gameplay that's more similar to playing
a game of masterful chess than it is
playing the slots
create and join guilds to play with said
friends in order to assist with heroic
dungeons or the challenges that come
with the compelling campaign
with over 100 heroes to choose from and
also hundreds of levels and dungeons and
dragons to defeat with new content being
added every single week
well i think it's time to set off in an
adventure don't you click the link in
the description below to get your dragon
slaying friendly adventurous spirits set
ablaze
the game is available on the app store
and google play so we both know you have
no excuse
i'll see you on the dragon side friend
spoiler alert for those who have not
played skyward sword and have not heard
its story in the past 10 years and are
planning on picking up the hd remaster
this summer
this video will absolutely spoil the
ending of the game so keep that in mind
going forward
if i had a penny for every timeline
theory about the zelda franchise that's
ever been created
i'd have like a dollar maybe okay maybe
not the best example but the point is
there are a lot of timeline theories in
circulation regarding the beloved legend
of zelda franchise and for good reason
too
the timeline itself is not the simplest
thing to comprehend
but if there's a certain section of it
that is simple to understand
it would have to be the section that
encompasses from its beginning until
right before its infamous split
however did you know that within this
simple little straight line portion of
the timeline
there's another possible timeline split
its existence does depend on how you
define
time travel within the games but the
fact remains that it is a definite
possible
other timeline that nobody really draws
any attention to
probably because it's not present on any
of the timeline charts we normally see
including the official timeline on
zelda.com
which is why this video has to be
classified as a theory
so let's theorize this proposed timeline
split occurs in skyward sword
how i'm so glad you asked let's recap
real quick you see throughout the entire
course of the game link periodically has
to battle a large threatening avocado
with legs named the imprisoned towards
the end of the game
link wishes upon the triforce for the
destruction of said avocado also known
as
demise and that's exactly what happens
through the power of the triforce the
isle of the goddess
breaks apart from the rest of the
floating city of skyloft and plunges to
the surface
turning the avocado into guacamole
sorry i had to say it point is it
crushes demise and literally
kills him ends his existence through the
aforementioned power of a wish upon the
triforce which for all intents and
purposes
is omnipotent this is all well and good
but demise's faithful assistant girohim
thinks up a plan and acts on it pretty
quickly
and this is where the timeline split
comes in
girohim with his master now dead decides
to use the gate of time to resurrect his
master
in the past he snatches zelda the
incarnation of the goddess hylia and
begins using her to resurrect demise
link chases after him battles enormous
hordes of monsters and ultimately gear
him himself before
he fails anyway and right before his
eyes
zelda's essence is extracted and used to
resurrect the big bad guy himself
so ultimately in the past girohim
actually wins
of course right after this link battles
demise unfortunately for the rest of the
world is actually able to win
after which zelda's essence returns to
her body and link returns the sword to
its pedestal and the entire group
returns to their original timeline with
link and zelda living on the surface
alone
happily ever after when you just lay the
story out flat like this
it seems pretty obvious that since there
were two timelines present in the game
there must have been another timeline
split right
well it's actually not as clear-cut as
you would think you see there's one
specific argument against the existence
of this timeline split that i'd like to
go over in this video
and that would be none other than impa
you know
this lady who is also this lady but at
two separate points in time
see some people claim that the fact that
she literally ages before your eyes when
traveling through the gate of time
implies that it's the same timeline
simply rewinding and fast forwarding a
closed loop if you will
i'll admit her age is some pretty solid
evidence for this point that would
seemingly prove that there is no
disconnect between the two points in
time
but this wouldn't be a theory video if
there was not some very key evidence we
can use to counter the argument
you see at the end of the game after
link defeats dubais and seals him away
and the group is leaving young impa in
the past
zelda gives impa her bracelet as a
goodbye which is then used to reveal the
old lady's identity as
old impa when they return to the future
or their original timeline right after
it's a very sweet moment but
it doesn't actually make that much sense
why you ask well take a good look at old
impa here now let's rewind
all the way to before any of this
adventure takes place to the first time
link descends upon the surface and meets
the old lady inside the temple who we
now know is impa herself
take another good look at her now take a
closer look
notice anything peculiar yeah she's
already wearing the bracelet
the same bracelet that zelda gives her
in the past
but not yet because she hasn't been to
the past yet see okay now this is
getting a little confusing to talk about
but basically in our original timeline
we're looking at right now
which follows our main characters of
link zelda and gruese
zelda has yet to give impa her bracelet
so how does impas already having the
bracelet at the beginning of the game
make any sense at all
actually i'll admit that i don't have a
solid explanation for that just yet but
one thing that it does disprove is the
idea that the timeline is one enclosed
loop because if it was just as simple as
rewinding and fast forwarding the same
timeline
then impa could not have the bracelet at
this point she would only have the
bracelet after zelda gives it to her in
the past and then returns to the present
since that would happen after this point
in time now with imba's age being
disproved as a counterpoint can we
instead prove that the timeline actually
splits in skyward sword
using the logic that the franchise
already uses for its other
infamous timeline split yes we can
actually you see one thing is clear to
me about ocarina of times timeline split
and that is that it was not originally
intended to
be a timeline split but rather just a
closed loop
we can tell that this was most likely
the case because of link's age
see it would be one thing if it operated
like the heroes of skyward sword where
he was the same age going forwards and
backwards in time which would imply that
no matter what timeline he's currently
in
he still comes from his original
timeline and therefore he doesn't belong
to the ones he's traveling in between
but the fact that he ages similar to how
people feel about
impa implies that he belongs to both of
the timelines you travel to
since it's the same link that means that
it has to be the same
timeline however nintendo soon after
decided to actually split the timeline
instead of just have a closed loop
which is evidenced in the opening
cinematic of the wind waker where they
reference
link in the adult timeline who to the
rest of the world appeared and then
disappeared from time
this completely rewrote the definition
of time travel in the zelda universe
now we can assume that any time travel
is actually
a timeline split based on what happened
with ocarina of time
in fact we just saw another timeline
split with the release of age of
calamity now again
very slight spoiler alert here but i'm
of the opinion that age of calamity is
simply non-canon
however there are many out there who
believe it is canon
but that it just takes place in an
alternate or split timeline because of
the time travel that takes place
add this zelda time travel logic to the
unexplained bracelet on impa's wrist and
couple that with the fact that our
heroes and skyward sword remain the same
age when traveling to the past
unlike the hero of time implying they do
not belong to that timeline and that
their own timeline now overlaps with the
past one
and you've got yourself multiple layers
of proof for a timeline split
and now finally i present to you the
perfect
timeline the one where demise and
therefore the curse of the demon tribe
was defeated by the absolute power of
the triforce and link and zelda lived on
the surface for the rest of their days
the original timeline in skyward sword
is this
perfect timeline one that amounted to
nothing but
peace in the ages to come because the
world was rid of the eternal curse
placed upon the goddess by the will of
demise
another final piece of evidence for the
split between timelines is the fact that
the isle
of the goddess is shown on the surface
in the original timeline
if they defeated demise in the past why
would the wish to defeat him
ever have existed in the present meaning
the isle of the goddess would never have
descended in the first place
this also means that every single game
to come had to have existed in skyward
sword's past timeline the one where
demise lived long enough to curse the
goddesses before being sealed away
will we one day get a game positioned
inside the perfect timeline
who knows it would have to come with the
reveal of an all-new villain with no
ties to the curse
but this is all just my theory what did
you guys think
does skyward sword split the timeline
into one with the triforce's wish
ridding the world of demise and one
without let me know in the comments
below
and thank you all so much for watching
if you enjoyed the skyward sword theory
please leave a like so we can build the
hype surrounding its hd release later
this summer
personally i think it was so underrated
and that it deserves much more attention
than it got previously
be sure to subscribe to the channel if
you haven't already for much more
nintendo content to come
as always huge thanks to my bandit crew
who make my day
every single day and say hello to the
new face of virtua master
who just joined up and to kdb and brett
h who both decided to upgrade their
levels
you guys mean the world to me and i'm so
excited that you've joined up with my
elite crew
if you watching are interested in
becoming one of the bandits check out
that join button located below or the
links in the description for my patreon
and merch pages
every little bit helps the next video
come to life so for those of you
thinking about it thank you so much in
advance
that's all i've got for this one so
check out some of my other videos if
you've got some time
i hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day and once again this is mastenton
abandoned
signing out see you next time peace
[Music]
you